ja es gibt wirbel im prozess um den
missbrauchten magen
der richter soll dem pädophilen
angeklagten akten mit
kinderpornografischen bildern ins
gefängnis mitgegeben haben laut
landgericht handelt es sich um ausdrucke
digitaler medien die als urkunde im
sogenannten selbst leseverfahren im
prozess verwendet werden sollten
gerichtssprecher volker talarowski sagte
zu bild in diesen berichten befinden
sich auch abbildungen die
pornographische inhalte waren die
abrichtung sollen aber geschwärzt worden
sein dass sie im sinne des gesetzes
nicht mehr als kinderpornografie gelten
zudem müsse der angeklagte sie
zurückgeben
die nebenklage ist natürlich trotzdem
schockiert und es ist nur ein weiterer
tiefpunkt im fall von marvin und den
ermittlungen und diesen fall haben wir
jetzt noch einmal für sie
zusammengefasst
922 tage lang fehlte von marvin aus
duisburg jede spur
am ende juli 2017 wird der damals
13-jährige schüler zum letzten mal an
diesem kiosk gesehen in
nordrhein-westfälischen oer-erkenschwick
dort lebt marvin in einer
jugendhilfeeinrichtung weil es zu hause
probleme gegeben hatte die polizei
versucht den jungen unter anderem über
sein handy zu orten ohne erfolg für
marvins mutter manuela beginnt die
schlimmste zeit ihres lebens auf
facebook und der fernsehsendung
aktenzeichen xy sucht sie nach ihrem
sohn
[Applaus]
in ihrer not wendet sie sich sogar in
einem hellseher der behauptet im januar
2009 10er könnte marvin tot im wald
liegen sehen
die polizei sucht mit spürhunden an der
angegebenen stelle findet aber nichts
tatsächlich gefunden wird der junge dann
am 20 dezember 2009 10 durch einen
zufall
wegen schwerer sexualstraftaten
ermittelt die polizei in einem haus an
der hochstraße in recklinghausen in der
wohnung von lars h suchen die beamten
eigentlich nach kinderpornografie nach
abbildungen von schwerem sexuellem
kindesmissbrauch
doch dann entdeckten die beamten den
vermissten marvin in einem schrank
offenbar hatten der 44 jährige lars h
und dessen 77 jähriger vater den
teenager versteckt als die polizei an
der tür klingelt gegen lars h wird
haftbefehl erlassen
später kommt heraus bei der suche nach
marvin gab es offenbar eine
ermittlungspanne bereits im juli 2009 10
hatte eine zuschauerin von aktenzeichen
xy einen hinweis auf den aufenthaltsort
des jugendlichen gegeben er werde von
einem pädophilen in recklinghausen
festgehalten
die polizei telefoniert daraufhin mit
einem weiteren mann der den beamten
sogar den namen von lars h nimmt doch
der hinweis kam offenbar ohne weitere
ermittlungen zu den akten die
staatsanwaltschaft hat deshalb
vorermittlungen gegen beamte der
duisburger polizei eingeleitet das habe
sich unterdessen vor gericht
verantworten
ihm werden vergewaltigung schwerer
sexueller missbrauch und 472 fälle von
sexuellem missbrauch des jugendlichen
marvin vorgeworfen was passiert ist also
ich setze meine ich habe so viel wut und
hass sitzen überall kracht und passend
dass er die gerechte strafe bekommt und
setzt da mein ganzes denken rein und das
das ende sein wird da sagen wir
sicherheitsverfahren kommt und mir
irgendwelche kindern oder jugendlichen
was antun kann
nun hat lars h also
kinderpornografisches material im
gefängnis erhalten wie das überhaupt
sein kann darüber möchte ich nun
sprechen mit marie link genau sie ist
mir zugeschaltet und anwältin der
nebenklage
von inga erst mal ganz konkret rechtlich
die frage warum genau bekommt der täter
solche bilder jetzt ins gefängnis
naja die unterlagen wurden im das selbst
fans an den angeklagten übergeben
wenn das aber ein normaler normaler gang
der dinge ist warum genau ist das jetzt
in ihren augen in diesem fall ein
problem wir haben gehört die aufnahmen
sollen zumindest zu teilen geschwärzt
worden sein
die pressemitteilung des landgerichts
hierzu gehörten eine danach handelt es
sich bei der unteren lagen schon und
über den abbildungen die in den
unterlagen enthalten sind um
pornografisches im kinderpornografisches
material richtig ist dass an den bildern
schwärzungen vorgenommen wurden sind
geschwärzt wurden ihr die primären
geschlechtsteile der abgebildeten kinder
meines erachtens ist das nicht
ausreichend um den kindern den bildern
aber den kinderpornografischen charakter
zu nehmen sind denn diese bilder in
irgendeiner art und weise notwendig um
das verfahren des setzt leese verfahrens
rechts zu tun oder hätte man diese
bilder auch ganz weglassen können
nein der übergang in diese abbildungen
hätte es nicht bedurft selbst lese
verfahren wie der name es sagt bedeutet
dass urkunden die verletzbar sind
geleaster sind an verfahrensbeteiligte
zum zweck des selbst lesens übergeben
werden können das ist wie so eine art
hausaufgabe für die
verfahrensbeteiligten um ein bisschen
ökonomischer zu arbeiten in einem
prozess bilder gehören grundsätzlich
nicht in das eps dieses verfahren bei
der damals schon sagt man diese ja nicht
lesen kann wir müssen vielmehr im rahmen
der einnahme in die hauptverhandlung
eingeführt werden und das halt im
gerichtssaal kann sie uns außerdem auch
seinen bis marvin jetzt heute geht man
bemüht sich mit ganz viel
therapeutischer hilfe und auch mit der
hilfe seiner familie zurück in ein
normales leben das ist nach der langen
zeit die er jetzt etwas erlebt haben was
auf keinen fall normal ist
vater und auch langer weg aber er bemüht
sich sehr das was ihnen extrem belastet
ist das verfahren das er immer noch
läuft und sicherlich auch noch einige
zeit in anspruch nehmen wird und die
tatsache dass so wie es bislang aussieht
er auch in anwesenheit des angeklagten
seine aussage machen muss ja das stellen
uns alle sehr schwierig für ihn vor ist
denn das jetzt schon sicher darüber gab
es ja streit vor gericht ist das jetzt
bestimmt dass er das machen muss oder
kann da sich noch etwas von ändern also
bestimmt ist es noch nicht
das landgericht ist zu der auffassung
gelangt dass trotz der vorlage
therapeutischer als ärztlicher
stellungnahme und auch eine
stellungnahme eines sozialpädagogen
keine anhaltspunkte dafür bestünden oder
nicht ausreichend anhaltspunkte dafür
gefunden dass
[Musik]
ein erheblicher nachteil für das wohl
von marvin auftritt wenn er in
anwesenheit des angeklagten aussagen
müsse
dieser fernseher sind letztendlich vom
oberlandesgericht hamm entschieden
werden und wir hoffen natürlich dass das
oberlandsgericht haben sich hier den
experten anschließt und die sache im
sinne von marvin entscheidet verfolgt
marvin denn den prozess ansonsten und
wenn ja wie man versucht eigentlich sich
abzuschotten
es ist auch mit der mutter von namen
gesprochen dass über den prozess zu
hause so wenig wie möglich geredet wird
wie gesagt zum martin ist das eine große
belastung und er hat für sich so den weg
gefunden das eigentlich wegschiebt
vielen dank frau langlauf kennen dank